Mars harbors, lots of mysteries and star contrasts,
endless Barron stretches of Rocky wasteland lie next to tremendously high
volcanoes and the planet surface in general bears witness to countless
collisions in the distant past with gigantic canyons and craters.
As their solid reminder,
a rare atmosphere is saturated with minuscule particles of rusty sound
with strong winds, swirling it in continuous furious sand storms.
This is what Mars is like a mysterious and forbidden planet.
Let's take a closer look at it.
Mars lies approximately one and a half times as far from the sun as the earth in
contrast to our planet, its radius is twice as small.
Its mass is around 10.7% that of the earth and the free fall acceleration on
the surface is almost three times as low.
The temperature fluctuates between 153 degrees Celsius below zero
at the poles and 35 degrees Celsius above zero at the equator.
The area of Mars's surface is roughly the same.
A start of all our continents combined its terrain is extremely diverse
with some geologic features reminiscent of those of our planet and others
quite unique and peculiar.
The surface of Mars is currently closely observed from the planet's orbit by
eight automatic space probes.
The data collected by them reveals that there is a vast light spot in the
planet's west and hemisphere.
This region is the largest volcano in the solar system,
and it is known as Olympus Mons. Today.
This is the starting point of our tour around the red planet,
Olympus Mons towers,
as high as 26 kilometers over the planes surrounding it.
This is roughly two and a half times. The height of Mount Everest.
It has assumed to be a shield volcano formed with multiple sheets of solidified
lava. According to today's assumptions about the planets in a makeup,
there are no tectonic plates under the surface,
which is why magmas eruption point can remain in the same spot for a long time
for hundreds of millions and even billions of years.
That accounts for the fact why ejected lavas builds out to cover incredibly vast
areas with a layer that subsequently turns into a Rocky shield.
The average diameter of Olympus MOS measures around 600 kilometers and its air
is over 300,000 square kilometers.
These figures are compar with the area of an average sized European country like
Poland or Italy,
a giant depression formed with six Calders or collapsed.
Volcanic CRAs is located in the center of the volcano.
The diameter of the depression measures around 85 kilometers and its depth
reaches as far down as three kilometers.
Olympus MOS is so high that the atmospheric pressure,
the top is 50 times lower than the foot.
Since the atmosphere on Mars is about 160 times more rarefied
than that of the earth.
The conditions on top of the volcano are slightly short of those in the vacuum.
That is why the red planet's highest mountain cannot expect any visitor probes.
The atmospheric density would be too low for parachutes to slow down a
dissenting capsule with a MAs Rover inside with the average slope
of Olympus WANs quite at only 5%,
the volcanoes edges Ando cheer bees of up to seven kilometers
high.
It still hasn't been established for certain how such enormous slopes came to
form. According to some assumptions,
it was done by an ancient ocean on Mars are the hypothesis held sand storms
accountable, which can continuously rage in this area.
When we climb down from Olympus, swans and fly over its surroundings,
we can see that there are lots of overlapping ridges and isolated mountains.
Some of these formations stretches far as a thousand kilometers from the
volcano's edge.
It is assumed that they may have formed as the giant mountain slopes eroding or
else due to movements of ancient icecaps whizzing on Southeast
from Olympus Mons, we will find ourselves in a vast Trin known assis.
This volcanic Oland formed by solidified streams of lava covers roughly
one fourth of the entire planet surface its area of around 30 million
square kilometers is comparable with that of Africa. Interestingly,
the Upland is 10 kilometers higher than the planes surrounding it.
And its age could be about 3.7 billion years.
There are great number of volcanoes here.
Some of which only slightly smaller than Olympus Mons are sea among for
example, rises as high up as 19 kilometers,
which makes it the second highest peak on Mars with a summit Calera
measuring 110 kilometers.
The overall diameter of the mountain is over 400 kilometers.
A unique natural phenomenon can be observed over the volcano every year for a,
your time as sunrises warm, the mountain slopes,
small dust spirals into a dense cloud helped along by air streams going
upward.
This cloud may float up to 30 kilometers above our sea Mons and may be
scattered by winds across vast areas.
Vertical pits can be seen in different places all over the Oland.
They're quite deep with the bottoms, quite unobservable,
the diameter of the largest one measures around 150 meters and its
depth can be less than 178 meters.
These pits are thought to be collapsed.
SL tubes Farsis is made up of dozens of overlapping shield
volcanoes in the billions of years of their eruptions.
Great amounts of CO2 and water vapor were released into the Martian atmosphere.
Mathematical modeling shows that the amount would be enough to shroud the planet
with an atmosphere one and to half times has dancers out of the earth.
These estimates are in direct evidence of the fact that in the past conditions
on Mars may have been more favorable for life to originate there than now with
its gravity, comparatively weak. However,
the planet failed to retain its atmosphere and was eventually stripped of it.
Move on the east from the plateau.
We will get to the region known as VALIS marinara.
It is a network of Gargan and canyons stretching for up to
4,500 kilometers.
The width of the canyon reaches 600 kilometers and its more than 11 kilometers.
Deep
images reveal that the slope of most of the canyons and the central and Western
parts of valley marinara have a stratified structure.
Typical of deposits at the bottom of a large body of water.
It is quite likely that the canyons used to be completely submerged under water
in the distant past.
There are some truly invaluable paleontological fines to be extracted from the
rock deposit it's in this region.
The Eastern part of the valleys are areas with a rather chaotic relief.
There are vast labyrinths made up of comparatively small canyons,
abyss mountains and plateaus further north the terrain evens
out into a relatively smooth plane known as Christia.
It last areas became the final resting place for the debris of this Adur Mars
Rover and also for the Viking one probe,
which sent to the first color images of marsh landscapes to the earth as far
back as in 1976,
according to the widely accepted hypothesis today VALIS marinara came
to be in the early stages of the planet's formation,
erosion and geological processes were to deepen and widen the canyons later
on one version,
has it that the systems of Kasmar is thought to have formed after volcanic
eruptions on the Farsis Upland.
Another version claims utopia Pia to be the cause for their formation,
which lies on the other side of the planet.
This vast round lowland is likely to be an impact crater from an extremely
large asteroid that would've hit the planet's surface.
The Lanius diameter measures some 3,300 kilometers.
The terrain of the surface itself is rather flat and smooth.
There were several attempts to explore ETOP Pania by different space probes
in 1979,
the Viking Toland beamed back panoramic images of its surface to the earth
in 2016,
the shard radar on the MRO probe located rich deposit of water ice
mixed with dust underground in May, 2021,
the Chinese Rover Ang touched down on utopia. Pia.
It has covered over 1000 meters of the red planet surface by now and has beamed
back hundreds of images.
Unfortunately it cannot dig as far down as the water can airing layer
with a ladder as deep as one to 10 meters down in the north
utopia, Pia borders on vests Borealis,
a giant lowland surrounding the Northern part of the planet and covering about
40% of its total area.
Moving Southwest from the center of utopia Pia, we will reach it.
ISIA the region on its Western edge has been the focus of people's special
attention for almost state months.
Now, of course it is all about the Jesu crater.
It is likely that millions of years ago,
there used to be a body of water here that has dried up by now the
perseverance Mars Rover and ingenuity,
the first ever helicopter flown beyond the earth have been exploring the bottom
of the crater since the 18th of February, 2021.
The Jesu crater was chosen from the mission because it appeared one of the most
promising places to discover traces of marsh and life.
The crater is positive to have formed around 4 million years ago,
after a massive celestial body fell on Mars,
the impact crater measured some 49 kilometers. As I've already mentioned,
it is thought that it used to be filled with water and the Hasper of the
geological history of Mars is singled out as the most likely period for that
Theen started some three and a half billion years ago and continued for round a
billion years.
Atmospheric pressure on the planet at the time is estimated to have been
comparable with that on the earth with the surface temperature reaching 50
degrees Celsius rock samples recently extracted from the Crater's bottom
by the perseverance Rover, a hard evidence of that.
They still have to be transported to the earth for deeper analysis,
but it is clear even now that at some point the rocks have continuously been in
close contact with liquid water.
Perseverance has already delighted scientists with great amounts of useful data.
And the mission is still far from being completed.
The probe is designed for 14 years of operation,
which means that there are still hundreds of fines to extract and kilometers of
Martian terrain to cover.
That is why our tour around Martian expanses is not yet over
with all the considerable effort put into studying it.
The red planet still harbors and hummable mysteries.
Some bold predictions may come true even in the nearest years.
And humans will finally set food on the Martian surface for the first time ever.
This event will be a new major milestone in the exploration of the solar system
and the beginning of a new era of discoveries. And as they happen,
we will do our best to bring your updates on all of them.
Your support means a lot to us. Let's keep in touch.
I.